this video is a collaboration with
beautiful science be sure to check out
their incredible channel after the video
so if you're like most people you've had
a vision of your potential future self
the more successful better groomed
richer happier version of yourself
but you've probably also wondered if you
can actually become this person or if
this person is just a figment of your
reckless imagination because sometimes
the contrast between who you are and who
you want to be seems so stark you wonder
if this idea of your potential is even
attainable or is it just an instrument
of false hope like a carrot to a mule
after all
while some few people really do achieve
their dreams and change the world the
vast majority of others don't they don't
even come close so what's the difference
between these two types of people and
how can we not let our dreams be dreams
and actually become the person we think
about when the word potential is thrown
around author Jeff Olsen suggests that
there is a reliable tactic you can use
for achieving success whatever that may
mean to you there is a surefire way to
make massive progress in any area of
your life and it's not as hard as you
might think so here it goes everyone who
has ever been successful understood this
thing called the slight edge they may
not have called it the slight edge but
the slight edge was without contention
the main factor in them achieving
success so how does it work ok so say
you had a ridiculously rich uncle who
was feeling really generous one day and
he said to you Kevin my boy I'll give
you two options
either I give you 1 million dollars cash
right now and you can walk out the door
a millionaire or I give you a single
penny one cent and I will double it
every day for a month that accent was
all over the place which option would
you choose gut instinct tells you option
1 but if we do some simple math option 1
gives you 1 million dollars it's pretty
simple math but if you had the patience
and perseverance to stick it out for 30
days option 2 gives you five million
three hundred and sixty eight thousand
seven hundred and nine dollars and
twelve cents over five times the value
of option one which is weird because
with option two for the vast majority of
those days this money doubling seems
like a waste of time after 20 days of
doubling you would have only had a
little over $5,000 at that point if you
were Kevin you definitely would have
thought you'd up big-time
but by sticking with it dramatic change
happens so here's another example sure
you can hit the gym really hard one day
like the best heaviest work out of your
life just straight barbaric and
afterwards you do everything right you
have a giant protein rich meal and a
long restful night's sleep but
unfortunately even after all that you
won't see any results
visually you'll be just as big as you
were before you went in fact if you were
to skip the gym that day altogether in
the grand scheme of things it wouldn't
really make a difference if you asked a
friend how you look before and after
your workout assuming there is no such
thing as being swole they'd say you look
the exact same that's because you don't
get to have huge muscles by going to the
gym harder than everyone else that one
time you're motivated enough to go to
the gym you get to have huge muscles by
just showing up to the gym every single
day for a long period of time so the
slight edge can all be boiled down to
this success is not the result of doing
difficult extraordinary things but
rather the result of doing unremarkable
relatively easy to do things every
single day over a long period of time
maybe you want to write a book if that's
the case then you shouldn't think about
it in terms of somehow possessing the
massive inspiration to crank out 200
brilliant pages of literature because
you already know that's never gonna
happen if you want to write a book write
half a page and then be done for the day
then when you wake up the next morning
finish that page and take a break make
writing half a page into a simple daily
habit and it'll eventually turn into a
well-oiled machine that will easily take
you to your goal by casually showing up
every single morning to write a
relatively easy amount of words after a
year's time you'll have written one
hundred and eighty two point five pages
that's a book and you did it with hardly
any strain and that's because writing
half a page is easy something you're
actually likely to do but when leveraged
by time half a page turns into a book 45
minutes at the gym turns into a
beachbody 30 minutes of practicing
guitar turns into holy Fred I didn't
know you're such a good musician so if
you want to achieve massive progress in
your life in any particular area break
it down into a tiny little action
something easy so easy that you're
actually likely to do it but make sure
to do it every single day because as
easy as it is to do it's just as easy
not to do and doing it or not doing it
is the difference between a life of
success and one of mediocrity later down
the road
[Music]
so I'm in a really small town in
northern Saskatchewan called Buffalo
narrows don't know if you guys have
heard of it but anyways I just wanted to
say that if you enjoyed this video go on
over to Chris
Chris's channel it's beautiful science
the link is in the description of the
video and go subscribe to his channel
because I think he's super underrated he
did a great job animating this video so
thank you very much Chris if you like
videos like these hit that subscribe
button hit that like button in order to
improve the rankings and so that this
video shows up and helps some people out
but yeah hope you enjoy the video a
little bit of a different style this
time but I'm gonna continue to
experiment on this channel forever so if
you want to hop along for the ride hit
that subscribe button catch you the next
video and see you in the Facebook group
guys have a great day